he's one of my good friends he's known
as uncle Marshall in my household he is
a pro Football Hall of Famer and he is
Marshall Faulk here in the rich Esther
how are you Marshall we're just talking
about this UFC plan about G about this
Dana White's getting his own private
island and flying fighters there to have
fights is that you know do you know
about this place
Marshall you know a lot of places no no
idea
no I have not heard about it okay wow
that's interesting it's not the place
where Zeke went last summer no no no not
not not the same place interesting rich
I mean it's just like because it looks
like he's gonna fly people there and
we're gonna do fights it'll be a lot of
fun and just check it out you know it's
a weekly he's gonna do weekly fights
there Marshall he's gonna do there
here's my question yes here's the
question is er if someone catches cold
very dare yes candidate well that's
interesting you asked about liability
issues on this front there's a lot of
labor laws that have been potentially
these these are I'm sure things that
he's going through right now but he I
think he is he is somebody that wants to
get up and running and he wants to keep
his business going and he also knows
that there's a captive audience which is
part of reason why I believe you know
we've got the NFL Draft later on this
month you know that we're gonna with
that that there is a need and a desire
for a lot of sports fans to try and feel
normal we get that out there and you
know and try and figure out how you can
get back to normal Marshall I mean you'd
sit back and watch a fight if you could
right oh yeah without a doubt no no
don't get me wrong we there's a there's
a there is a I think more than ever we
are we would sit back and we was we
would like when when the when they were
came and in these
and CBS and Fox will pay me billions for
this NFL contract or they pay for
basketball or baseball or NASCAR we say
oh my god that's crazy money now we see
what the cost of live entertainment
really is like we see what it's worth
and what it means so it's uh it is it is
necessary and um are we are we are
thirsting for it and I think the players
just the sense of community and team so
then the hazard if they're thirsty for
it so Marshall Faulk here on the Rich
Eisen show all right Marshall let's
let's get into a little bit of what I
wanted to hit with you the NFL
all-time I guess all-decade team of the
teens came out yesterday what'd you
think of the running back group that got
named from Adrian Peterson LeSean McCoy
Marshawn Lynch and Frank Gore what'd you
think of that deserving deserve it
bridges great group of guys man and and
and they yeah I think the guy that's
right they got it right rich they got it
right I'm talking guys and put up
numbers not not only numbers the
longevity if you just look at long the
longevity and and how long they played
and teams that they carried him and and
what they what they have meant to the
game so this is a really really good and
I think that I think that you know each
one of those guys will eventually wear a
gold jacket mm-hmm do you think okay
LeSean McCoy is a Pro Football Hall of
Famer Marshall yeah yeah yeah yeah
here's the thing here's the thing rich
and I just want to I want to clarify
they're like are we are we and and and
when we say that we usually think the
first thing the first thing we take is
the first thing we think is are we
taught them first
are we talking will he eventually get in
I think he will eventually get in his
numbers and what he's meant to the game
lashauwn is um you know and you got to
think about some of the things that he
has done he's done on teams that I
didn't have much around him at times so
I think that I think that LaShawn would
be the one person that you could ask
that question about and and I must say
that he might be the one that only one
that you could ask about but the rest of
the guys without a doubt that there
didn't is well I mean that's why I'm I'm
you know i mentioned mccoy specifically
when you said you think all four of them
are gonna get a jacket yeah I think the
stretch the stretch well I mean isn't
that the the running play he used to
like the most Marshall there you know a
a long time I don't shine shoes no more
Marshall you know I mean now how long
has it been since you and Chris Brockman
got into it when was the last time that
you guys have had some sort of football
conversation that you get back you get
into it okay Marshall now Chris does not
believe Frank Gore is a Hall of Famer
and I think he does speak for a lot of
people do you think Frank Gore is a I
guess you've already said that why do
you think Franco is a pro Football Hall
of Famer durability availability and you
know the numbers don't lie
it is what it is you know you can you
can say oh my god he played this long he
played this long he's supposed to have
those numbers well just tell me who
played that long I mean it's not like
he's playing he's not like it's not like
he's a kicker he's eventually don't get
there it's not
he's a quarterback who he just continued
to play he's gonna throw fit now he's
carrying the ball and and remember
remember what Eric just started off
playing in he started off playing in an
era when it was single back him only
totin of all that was that was Frank
Gore downhill Frank Gore with the lead
and he shifted his gain into this class
happy but he he still get there done I
mean that's I do yeah so it's not a
doubt man right no question well I guess
do you want to take this Chris cuz I
know you've been very bad I'm just
saying like you said rich I do think I
speak for a lot of people when it comes
to Frank or his one quote-unquote elite
season was in 2006 he's only rushed for
over 1,500 yards one time one season of
10 rushing touchdowns he's never led the
league in a single category not a single
category he had a little Pro Bowl
stretch there in the middle of his
career but it's like do you think you
should be rewarded for not getting hurt
like Craig Biggio isn't one of the
greatest players of all time he might be
the ultimate baseball compiler but he
just never got injured played 20 years
and made the Hall of Fame does that make
a hole Fame career
unfortunately brockman baseball is not a
contact sport Frank Gore played a
position that requires you to get hit
get tackled by guys sometimes double
your size get up and ask for the ball
some more so when you don't get hurt and
when you're readily available and you
play on teams with Frank Gore probably
has had the least amount of help from
the quarterback position out of anybody
who has ever played the position as long
as he plays think about it you can't
name a quarterback that's going to soon
the Hall of Fame or let alone even came
close to winning a playoff game or even
making it to the Super Bowl that Frank
Gore played with but yet he continues to
be durable it doesn't matter where you
put it doesn't matter doesn't matter and
guess what guess what else he does every
time you put him out there you say hey
friend you have to compete you have to
compete with somebody in order to like
win a job guess what he does he beats
the guy out and that includes a guy
named Rashawn McCoy that is true
marshall faulk here on the rich on do
you like that quarterback arguing yeah
well you know what and again too
I do have to say however I fully agree
with you Marshall
and it is true that baseball isn't the
contact sport is football
but bgo did lead the league every year
and hit by pitches right he did get hit
a lot
[Laughter]
Marshall now let's talk about current
running backs and the current status of
this market and you're very well-versed
in it again you were front and center
and counseling Zeke Elliott last year it
just seems to me we saw what Derrick
Henry did last year and he felt and this
may have been also to do with the fact
that coronavirus is ravaging our country
and maybe you just wanted to get paid
right now and he signs his tender todd
gurley signing one year six million for
the mat for you know if he if he gets
everything for his new contract what is
going on with this market Marshall
what's happening here so you you look at
you look at San Francisco and what they
did and usually the trend that the teams
that are in the Super Bowl that that's
the trend San Francisco you look at
their backfield you look at what Kansas
City had in their back heel you look at
the money that was spent and and that's
the trend that's what you feel like you
have to do but usually that's the case
you know he's running back by committee
and it's that that's what happens if you
don't
you don't deem yourself worthy of the of
the of the finances and the paycheck if
you're not a Tapout guy if you're not a
guy that wants to share the backfield
then you'll get paid handsomely and the
guys that that are that are getting paid
they are full service guys I'm telling
you right now it is not going to be a
bargain deal when Christian McCaffrey
back up the truck to Carolina is not
gonna be that kind of conversation he's
not gonna be about who else is sharing
the backfield with him it's just not
because he's not a guy that's taking
downs off he's not taking players off
he's maximizing their opportunity to
make his team better and that's what you
have to do that's how you have to play
the game so and then obviously you
didn't even mention Melvin Gordon and
what he had to do so um what what's your
counsel - running backs in today's game
you you have to demand your time on the
field
this whole sharing the backfield
preserving time is going to get you
these part-time contracts part-time play
part-time pay that's how it is Melvin
Gordon split time with Austin Eckler and
Justin Jackson and now he find himself
in giver once again he just be this
goodtime guy
once one cat becomes your mo and that's
how you play that's how you play that's
just how it is man you develop that you
you show them you like the rest and
that's what you need and guess what
that's the kind of back you are but if
you a full-service back and that's how
you play okay you play it listen rich
this league is when you when you when
you're a dog and you go out there and
you demand it they don't give it to you
they're gonna allow you and you're
proved that you can you can carry the
workload and you can handle it they're
going to give it to you they're not
going to pull you off the field they
don't notice the difference
of the game and how the defense react
when you are in the game compared to
when you are not and and it happened to
Kagura last year you know they started
they started to tune in and other guys
were in this they tried to get stuff
done without it actually the year before
when they made it to the Super Bowl
no you bring in you bring it CJ Anderson
off you know off the street and you make
it to the Super Bowl with Todd you know
not a hundred percent and it's like whoa
hold up wait wow we did that well let's
see let's see where we're going now
maybe there was some other things that
we don't know going on behind the scene
but once you once a team can see a
vision without you and there's a there's
a huge paycheck there they're going to
try to live that vision without you
because they don't want to have money
tied up into a position that if you get
injured other than quarterback that if
you get injured the season could
possibly go downhill fast
marshall faulk here in the Rich Eisen
show I mean you mentioned Gurley right
there and you said maybe there's some
things going on that we don't know about
we had Sean McVeigh on yesterday he I
mean we needed oxygen on the high road
that he took when I asked him was Gurley
hurt or not and was Gurley hurt or not
this is one of the great Bermuda
Triangle questions of the NFL up there
with Wadud Marshawn not get the ball and
why was Malcolm Butler active even
though he played one special team snap
in a Super Bowl that they lost to the
Eagles I mean what is going on what
happened with Gurley that you can share
with us Marshall
I have no let me let me make sure I say
this before because I don't want to you
know I have no inside source I didn't I
don't know anything about anything
but I know this rich here's what I know
in the last game in the very last game
of the season that being a Super Bowl
there is no way if I was not hurt that
they would have kept me off that field
okay trying to intimate I literally I
literally played in a Super Bowl with
broken ribs a hematoma in my in my thigh
you know I mean if there's a game that
you risk whatever it is score it's the
Super Bowl you put it on the line you
just go down I let you go down your list
and think about heroic efforts of what
people hasn't done I mean you remember
tio coming back
of course lay in a Super Bowl those is
amazing ha I think I think rot rod came
back rod way with his knee yep point in
the Super Bowl yeah man just just think
about what people have done just to play
in that game so are you are you saying
then that he was hurt that's why he
wasn't out there or he tapped his helmet
there's no helmet tapping todd gurley
has lived for that that he's been
playing football to be in that position
drink he had to not be himself in order
to not be out there well he had a pass a
physical to be in Atlanta and they
signed that deal Monday night so you
know that or Tuesday morning I don't
know the exact time where pain was put
to paper so it looks like Atlanta's
getting a healthy running back one would
think right well we just don't know
still like I said we will we will find
out and I I'm gonna say that I hope I
would I want nothing with the best
retire I want
to return but Todd is defied I wouldn't
hurt his knee in Georgia we had no idea
I was how he was going to bounce back
right and he sent out the first part of
the season his rookie year and came back
and crushed that dominated and and it
was just it was just amazing to watch
him and and that's what we want to see
we want to see that Todd Gurley I want
to see him have the career that he was
on pace to have you know I would have
liked to have seen that happen with the
Rams but we know things happen and
sometimes you have to take your talent
elsewhere and for Todd I just want him
there I want him to be successful last
one for you I'm not not not only it
sorry I don't know I didn't mean to
interrupt you I've last one for you
Marshall okay you know you know you were
there right next to Peyton Manning you
know that system you know Ariane's
you know what Ariens likes to do with
quarterbacks you know the whole thing
Brady with aryans and Tampa equals what
in your estimation that it's going to be
amazing
tom is going to and here's what Bruce
does Bruce is going to allow Tom to do
what he wants to do and he's just going
to make it better the most coaches can
only coach their system Bruce Arians can
coach anything and anyone and make it
better
so whatever Tom like Bruce is going to
learn that and say Tom here's what I
think about what you want to do and
think about it the guy who's going to be
in his ear as a guy who's played at a
high level as well and lesson which is
it's just a great marriage minute that I
like I like what they did from that
standpoint and I'm happy for Brady that
he got a guy like Darian set that knows
how to deal with just players in general
but definitely definitely veterans ma'am
Bruce's he's a player's coach so you
think in a way that Bray and do you
think Brady had that in New England or
not enough of it in New England and that
he's gonna thrive with that being hey we
know what you like this is
exactly how we're gonna do it like you
like it but in a way that I'm now seeing
it to help improve it and thus it'll be
more collaborative than than Brady
perhaps is used to would you agree with
that Marshall I must say I must say I
must say that Bruce is Bruce is
like-minded on often - with Belichick
there's on defense
you know how flexible Belichick is - we
are going to do whatever we need to do
yes to win on defense that's Bruce on
offense love it
so Bruce is going to whatever it is he's
going to make the necessary adjustments
it's not just about this is our system
this is what we do no it's about winning
games Marshall you know what is gonna
back what they've all gone - you're the
man Marshall everybody healthy in your
family I trust everybody good
everybody's good man everybody's good
yeah love it how about you thank
goodness everybody healthy but you know
those three kids in that household it's
it's lively it's lively it's lively
Marshall my kids are all note writers
they write notes to me and Susie and
they say shove it under the door when
when Susie and I are like on the phone
or something that give us the heads up
you know and and Taylor you haven't been
around Taylor for about six months she
is particularly vocal and any any great
letter writer a great letter writer a
great note-taker
no yeah so we're all working together
and what I love you Marshall miss you
let's let's let's connect obviously when
we can okay bud all right that's my man
that's my friend my buddy love Marshall
Faulk